what is my favorite book series ever  a the Twilight Saga B 50 Shades C Harry  Potter it's Harry I know I was too easy  though too easy you knew it was gonna be  too easy yeah what else you had  do you know I did  a bit of a soft it's a bit of a raw  point for me but I did the test on the  Pottermore website which is the legit  one and I'm actually in Hufflepuff and I  was really upset about that to begin  with but then I read why and actually I  think yeah wow why hufflepuffs are  actually very loyal friends and very  hard-working people that makes sense and  I thought I got a real friend and yeah  they yeah plus Cedric Diggory was in  Hufflepuff and he's a g so there you go